what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a fresh and fit clip
label this is how you deal with rude
girls warning they'll get mad before i
start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell as you guys know i'm trying to hit
20 000 subscribers each and every one of
you
helps okay so
[Music]
here we go guys i'm pulling an
all-nighter tonight
to make a flight so i'm just reacting to
videos
i'm posting them tomorrow but oh my gosh
i'm so tired
[Music]
all right so your turn on the clock um
okay so i'm gonna keep this uh nice
short and sweet so
this was uh less than a year ago this is
like like three four months ago
um i i went on a date with this chick
like german growth like real estate
agent whatever like every girl here in
miami florida
uh from south florida and uh when i went
out with her
uh i wasn't trying to drink so we went
to go get some tacos
and one of these spots down actually no
i'll say it no
i gotta say today all right yeah [ __ ]
them [ __ ] pillows bro they're the one
here in brickell trash
uh i hate that place but anyway that's a
whole other thing i was about to beat up
the owner but that's another that's a
whole other thing
so anyway i go there with the chick yeah
you you yeah
you have to go it is what it is yeah
[ __ ] that place
um so anyway i go there right
i go there with this chick right get the
[ __ ] up
i go there with this with this chick
right and and uh we're sitting there
and she orders her food i wasn't i
ordered like uh like an orange soda
because i just felt like having some
more soda this one time i hadn't drink
soda for a few months at this point
i was really on the fitness grind so i
was like i want this orange soda so she
orders her food whatever
and we're having a conversation so she's
like okay so tell me what's what's going
on with you like
you know what's up with you and the
girl's like what's going on i was like
well you know i'm just
you know i'm just seeing some girls
right now whatever just casually dating
whatever she
and she like just like abruptly like
like blurts so you're just [ __ ]
people and i was like
i was like look they're dead and yeah
and i was like
yo you're [ __ ] rude what's wrong with
you and she was like
oh well i didn't i didn't mean it like
that i was like like
did anyone like not teach you etiquette
like you know what i'm saying i don't
know she had like an accident someone
made me
she had been in the united states for a
bit maybe there was a language barrier
or whatever but
not i ain't gonna give her that excuse
she was just rude and one thing is if
you guys
know as you guys have seen on that's
very forward for a first
date dance show like i have a very low
tolerance for like rude women bro like
it like listen i'm not your boyfriend
i'm not some scent whatever like
i'm not with that you know what i'm
saying like i hate rude women it's like
a pet peeve of mine
if you disagree i'm totally cool with
that but you know what i'm saying like
don't don't be [ __ ] rude to me bro
because real talk the big reason why is
because
skipper stack people act crazy when they
know that they can't get hit you know
what i'm saying
and i ain't going to put my hands on no
woman i ain't going to do that
so a lot of these girls talk reckless so
i was like you know what
listen you enjoy your food i'm going to
go
so the food comes out around this time
right it came out pretty quick
so she looks at the food she looks at me
and she gets up
and she walks out and she is she's gonna
going out the door she's like go [ __ ]
yourself
and i was like whatever and then the two
dudes one of the owners in a restaurant
like a wait a waiter i'm like all right
whatever so i get up and i go pay for my
soul and like hey you got to pay for her
[ __ ]
and i was like nah [ __ ] i'm not paying
for her [ __ ] you [ __ ] drunk she's
like well you came with her
like dude you're on the hook i was like
listen bro she's an adult you could have
stopped there right there before she
walked out
and you didn't do nothing i'm not paying
for [ __ ] and i looked and then i was
like some
little short order dude i was like is
there a problem he's like
no just take it whatever i was like you
caught a [ __ ] cop snicker like we
could talk about this [ __ ] i ain't
paying for a [ __ ]
and you're not gonna make me look dumb
here and then he's like no whatever so i
paid for the [ __ ]
and i left and it is what it is but yeah
man she she uh she was acting rude and
that's not a woman that's crazy i like
did not realize girls were like that
brian yeah that's not okay she was
trying because she was a bodybuilder too
you know what
yeah man i have like a very short fuse
for rude women bro that [ __ ] gets me mad
like to another degree
that should be for across the board real
people in general like
yeah yeah no but but it's like it's like
it's even worse when it comes from a
woman because like
like your value as a woman comes from
your femininity you know what i'm saying
so like for you to be rude as a woman
like that's like not
like i look at it like a rude woman is
like the equivalent to like a dude
that's like soft like
like if someone like if you're out with
your man right i'll give you an exam the
equivalent right like
you're out with your man and like a dude
like bumps into you purposely
and your man doesn't stick up for you
you're gonna look at him like what the
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
that's that same repulsion that you have
for him being soft that's how men feel
about like masculine ass women like that
that are real
wouldn't you just compare a rude woman
to a rude man no it's not the same
and that's what you're right yeah i like
when my man is because i was going to
say i kind of like it
yeah like that's the thing like like i
always say men and women are like
everything that we do is opposites so
like like uh like
men don't like masculine women like i
don't like chicks that a lot of guys
don't like masculine that talk like this
or ghetto or whatever
what up bro like it's just that men
aren't gonna say that because
if a man like says anything negative
about a woman or criticizes her is
considered misogynistic you don't like
new york new yorkers
i don't like masking women period so if
a woman like calls me bro or talks to me
like a guy i'm like yo don't don't talk
to me like that that's weird i'm going
new yorkers
um they have a very tough exterior
i do think men can get away with being
rude more than women can
like i i would agree with that once you
break past that yeah
you put some game on it they really yeah
not get away sorry i'm gonna
preface that i think girls like get away
with it more but i think it's like
more unattractive on a girl than a guy
that's that's how i'm gonna say it
because
he's right like girls can't get hit so
they do push push though
and sometimes like you just gotta tell
me don't talk to me like that and
they're like oh
and then they'll like they'll come
correct it's just like that you have to
kind of like snap them out of it like yo
i'm not one of your [ __ ] like guy
friends that you could talk to like that
and my equivalent is like
what if i talk and start talking to you
like this oh my god i love your red
bottom see yeah i saw your face like
what the [ __ ]
that's okay guys
um yeah that was an interesting clip
um cute little story i guess i'm super
tired so i'm about to go finish packing
because we got a flight in about an hour
but thanks so much for watching this
video
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
as usual help me hit 20 000 subscribers
and i will talk to you guys next time